les étudiants tourangeau sous le choc
l'une de leurs camarades est morte hier
à trousseau après avoir fait une crise
cardiaque sur le campus froment de
l'université pour tenter de la ranimer
certains ont cherché un défibrillateur
cardiaque
en vain ce soir l'université s'explique
sur place on retrouve malvina roues le
drame a eu lieu hier matin ici sur le
site universitaire de fromont alors
qu'elle est en cours kadidia coulibaly
une étudiante âgée de 30 ans fait un
malaise cardiaque immédiatement
professeurs et camarades de classe
cherche un défibrillateur et il n'en
trouve aucun dans l'établissement la
jeune femme décède quelques heures plus
tard à l'hôpital trousseau
pourtant depuis le 1er janvier 2020
l'université à l'obligation d'installer
des défibrillateurs sur chacun de ces
sites dont celui de fromont qui
accueille chaque jour 500 étudiants les
appareils bien été commandés ils ont été
reçus mais pas tous installés
philippe dandrieux regrette profondément
ce dysfonctionnement et veut apporter
des réponses
il est effectivement un retard dans le
dans la construction dans l'installation
du défibrillateur à fromont ça c'est
bien sûr c'est pas le premier placé je
vous ai dit on en a reçu 30 on en place
et 22 il en reste huit 8 dont un qui
suppose un type de travail spécifique
on a lancé on a lancé depuis hier je ne
vous le cache pas une enquête
administrative pour voir comment pour
quelles raisons les délais
d'installation qu'il était aussi long
depuis hier matin c'est donc toute la
faculté de tours qui est endeuillée
les étudiants ne comprennent pas comment
un tel accident a pu arriver et dénonce
une négligence
les camarades de kadidia coulibaly
manifesté ce matin leur colère et leur
tristesse devant la fac des tanneurs fac
des tanneurs ou la cellule d'aidé
psychologique et d'écouté a été installé
l'autopsié de la victime va elle être
réalisée dans les prochains jours